aurore bergé député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines comparé à
une femme tondue après la seconde guerre
mondiale dans un tweet au compte
aujourd'hui suspendu bruno millièmes
député de la 9e circonscription menacée
de mort depuis l'annoncé d'un projet de
loi pour un pass vaccinale les élus de
la majorité sont pris à partie comme il
ya une brawn pie v qui a reçu plusieurs
menaces par mail et par lettre
manuscrite ces deux dernières semaines
d'inquiétude un peu de colère en fait
parce que l'inquiétude parce qu'on voit
que certaines de ces personnes qui font
ces menaces la passe à l'acte et ne
s'arrête pas à ce qui est déjà une
infraction pénale intimidations les
menaces et puis la colère parce que
lorsque vous vous engager en politique
vous avez des intentions de servir de
servir vos concitoyens de servir
l'intérêt général
vous faites le mieux que vous pouvez
dans cet engagement là qui est un très
bel engagement et vous n'imaginez à
aucun moment que cet engagement va vous
conduire à cette inquiétude moi je suis
plutôt de ce que ça renforce parce que
vous ne pouvez pas laisser le débat
public être ainsi des voiliers vous ne
pouvez pas laisser ces individus quels
qu'ils soient
abaissées ce débat est finalement le
réduire à néant donc je crois que il est
de notre rôle à nous qui avons décidé de
nous engager dans la vie publique de nos
battre de défendre le débat est
inlassablement de rappeler que tout doit
se résoudre par le dialogue et par la
démocratie face à ces dernières semaines
sous tension aurore bergé a lancé un cri
d'alert la député appelle à un front
commun un sentiment partagé par la
présidente de la commission des lois il
ya aussi est évidemment la réponse
judiciaire dans le sens où on ne peut
pas laisser passer de telles agressions
ne peut pas laisser passer une telle
violence donc il faut la condamner il
faut la condamner dans les tribunaux il
faut la condamner publiquement lorsqu'on
est responsable politique et sans
conditionnalité
ce mardi 11 janvier le président de
l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
réuni en soirée les ministres de
l'intérieur et de la justice pour faire
un point sur ces violences et sur la
réponse judiciaire a apporté